[music]
Our economic system in its current form is
simply not advanced enough to comprehend the
consequences of its own actions. It is like
a blind giant lumbering from continent to
continent leaving incalculable ruin in its
wake. I propose that we give this giant a
set of eyes so that it might tread more gently,
and maybe some day even look upon itself.
>>The lead of today will be judge not only
by how well we change our industries, but
also how well we lead our companies to make
positive influence on the world.
>>When choosing a leader, you choose a lead
who to show a good example to the others.
>>The way in which we are growing things,
the way in which we are making products, providing
services, is having an unexpected and disastrous
impact on the planet that we live on.
>>You need to change in attitudes and new
institutions to set the right incentives so
that water use becomes more efficient across
the world.
>>Everybody who takes action actually has
an effect on at least somebody. And obviously
the more powerful you are, the more influential
you are, the bigger the impact there can be
across the world.
>>It's not just in working together. It's
new ideas. It's creating new concepts. And
it's happening while we speak. It will challenge
the way we think. It will challenge the way
we work. And it will challenge the way we
work with others.
>>There needs to be a more equal division
between the company owner and the employee.
>>Just take all responsibility for your actions
and your inactions, and leave a nice legacy
for out children and our grandchildren.
>>Extend hands and over come obstacles to
make open trades and exchange of ideas, and
exchange of cultures, and exchange of people
easier. And with that we will have certainly
make the planet a better place.
[music]